[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle is one of
the makeup artists today is the
photographer today he's doing all the
cool photos it's Friday morning it is
the last day of that job the other
models are still sleeping nicely in
their pets I have to do makeup first so
I'm waking up more earlier so we're
gonna have some breakfast and then we're
gonna start this last
[Music]
never thing I'm here with the makeup
team again yoga
[Music]
so the makeup is finished I've got my
first outfit on we're gonna continue on
the second day let's go
[Music]
so the other two models joined they woke
up finally and we're starting the job
together here we go
[Music]
follow me down there's no one around
back take your socks but natural like
this so damn polite can make you feel
just like you were young
Daniel there's so much fun so sometimes
you guys ask what models eat right now
we're form four models here from four
different countries from South Africa
from Italy I mean Argentina sorry sorry
from Brazil and from France
now we were speaking yesterday about the
Italian family so this is what I'm
having this our brother here from France
from Paris and then here we have some
vegetarian foods here and then here we
have what
this Auto vegetarian kind of right Maria
yeah no crying everything so we still
gonna eat healthy
this is run to win four seconds crazy
what you've been there before me we
guys
you'll get to flop with me I can take
you down
thank you around
across walking dead like
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
baby so I'm crazy okay okay
guys
okay so we just finished the job we're
done for the two days other guys feel
good
sanitary courses with people's rounded
us so yeah it was really special and you
don't get this kind of job that often
here in China so this is really special
mariana also just wanted to say hi bus
is there in the back all you see is she
was on the phone
super model super busy cannot speak to
my friends here but if you guys would
give a tip to new models you know one
tip what tip would you give them be
confident be confident you have a chance
to eat Western foods in your body
Mariana how long have you been doing
modeling okay so we're not saying it
5050 and what if there's a girl
listening to you and she's 15 would you
say she should try modeling or not yes
but you need to be responsible and now
you need to be careful and you need to
be called follow your dreams trust
yourself
don't be shy
so what is the best thing about modeling
that you guys would say I meet new
people go to different countries
[Music]
get up some of the money grab some money
picked up cash all right that's it all
right guys we're gonna go have some
dinner and then I'm going back to
Shanghai I'm gonna sleep there in a
hotel then I'm off to South Africa and
you guys where you guys going go back to
Guangzhou Beijing Beijing
so we're saying goodbye to these guys
they going off to the airport I'm going
back to Shanghai in hotel so we just
have to say goodbye but if you travel
then go along yeah what's the fooling us
for never know if you're gonna be imma
let you go
I'm tired
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my beans down only tonight man i cool
it
hello well since I can't back up call me
and calm down
hi you swore to myself so I could feel
something else yeah I guess I had my bad
days but it doesn't mean I lost my side
you
three doors
a king
his crown we can just
girl
I'm sorry